Wow, this is a Callaway Corvette aerowagen
it is the most powerful car made in the us period.
It's supercharged with the supercharger pushing up all the way through the hood
767 Horsepower this car will go from 0 to 60 in 2.7 seconds. Which is nuts
So let's put it to the test. I'm going to head out to Rockaway for lunch,
and we'll see what this beauty can do
So Callaway the very same name that engineers golf clubs
modifies these Corvettes.
And in this aerowagen the main upgrade is the supercharged engine
and it's so fast
the fuel efficiency is
27 miles per gallon at speed on the highway
That's like prime optimum conditions, but it's still pretty incredible considering most cars with
757 Horsepower get Like 12 to 13 miles per gallon
So the Aerowagen part of the Callaway Corvette is totally new this year
It's a huge departure from what a typical corvette looks like and that's by design
The trunk is enormous, and that's what you're really getting by choosing to have this option
The interior is just like the regular corvette that you buy directly from Gm. It's very much like a cockpit
so the belt parkway isn't exactly the autobahn but I was able to get a feel for the strength of the supercharger
and I made it down to Rockaway beach in no time flat
The starting price is about 130 thousand dollars
the money goes towards the engineering that makes this car so powerful and fast
but still that is so much cheaper than what you might find at Ferrari or McLAren or Lamborghini
This can keep up with all of those cars, and it's a far less expensive